la Russie ne peut ni ne doit l'emporter
aussi longtemps qu'elle attaquera il
sera nécessaire que nous poursuivions
adaption modulons le soutien militaire
nécessaire à la préservation de
l'Ukraine et de son avenir l'image de la
matinée la voici volody myerselenski qui
reçoit le drapeau européen devant le
Parlement à Bruxelles tout un symbole le
mode de vie européen sont remis en
danger
pourquoi sait-on de les annihiler par
une guerre totalitaire parce que une
fois que l'Ukraine tombera c'est votre
mode de vie qui tombera il est surtout
venu réclamer des armes une demande
soutenue par la présidente du Parlement
qui interpelle les États membres
les États doivent envisager rapidement
de vous fournir les armes à longue
portée et les avions dont vous avez
besoin j'ai trouvé l'invitation de
zelinsky inapproprié car dans cette
affaire je crois que notre force est la
communauté et l'un je comprends les
questions de politiques internes ou le
fait de favoriser l'opinion publique de
son pays mais il y a des moments où ça
risque de se faire au détriment de la
cause et cela me semble être le cas ici
je pense qu'il faut privilégier
qu'il faut privilégier les livraisons
utiles pour mener ces opérations et
résister plutôt que des engagements qui
arriveront très tard ou très loin il a
raison de temporiser sur les chars
lourds mais que il va finir par les
livrer parce que il n'est plus autonome
on le voit à chaque fois il dit quelque
chose c'est un jusqu'au-boutiste et que
il ne joue pas sa réélection puisque de
toute façon il ne pourra pas se
représenter il y a le fait que la
feuille de route est donnée par
Washington à Bruxelles et par Bruxelles
à Paris qui nous dit il faut régler le
problème des retraites et faites-le et
qu'il a envie d'être un bon élève mais
en même temps finalement il le fait vous
bordéliser le pays
vous bordélisez en particulier
nos services publics vous êtes une bonne
d'hypocrite parce que lorsqu'il faut
taper oui vous êtes des hypocrites ou
quelqu'un vous écoute pas vous haussez
le ton et ben nous la façon dont c'est
le ton c'est de partir en grève
reconductible donc nous on partira en
grève conductible c'est pas une rumeur
c'est une menace bah oui oui il continue
à voter ici ils n'ont aucun respect pour
ce Parlement ils n'ont rien à faire ici
êtes-vous orgueilleux ou êtes-vous des
monstres je ne laisserai pas passer les
insultes envers les parlementaires de
mon groupe syndicat envisage de durcir
le mouvement à partir du mois de mars
avec un appel à la grève totale quel est
votre réaction alors je ne vais pas
m'exprimer sur des rumeurs moi je n'ai
pas encore de position de
l'intersyndicale donc on va écouter ce
que propose à inter syndical attention à
ce que le mois de mars 2023 ne soit pas
un remake d'une révolte populaire qui
soit plus grande que celle des gilets
jaunes lors de son premier quinquennat
l'art comme l'ancien CSA a condamné C8 à
une amende de 3 millions et demi d'euros
après les insultes de l'animateur Cyril
Hanouna au député Louis Boyard dans
l'émission Touche pas à mon poste c'est
le rôle de la recommande ensuite au
moment de faire le bilan de ses
obligations de vérifier qu'elles ont
bien été respectées pour pouvoir ensuite
évaluer si la reconduction de cette
fréquence et justifiée ou pas la vidéo
improbable de Valérie Pécresse au fan de
Beyoncé c'est vrai beaucoup ont rejeté
la faute sur la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France lorsqu'ils ont appris que
la chanteuse avait renoncé à une
deuxième date au Stade de France en mai
en raison de travaux sur le RER B C8 et
c'est news pourrait perdre leur
fréquence il y a des obligations à
respecter il y a déjà eu une vingtaine
d'interventions de l'arcom depuis 2019
pour C8 et cnews
au bout d'un combien d'interventions
pour moi l'art comme dire a-t-elle degré
les obligations ne sont pas respectées
c'est le rôle de l'arcom je rappelle
juste le cadre qui existe c'est
important Léa salam rigole car une
petite bombe vient d'être lâché un
retrait des fréquences de C8 et cnews en
2025 serait donc possible je n'y suis
rigoureusement pour rien j'ai le dollar
mais faut pas charrier